In India, police and protesters continued clashes for a fifth day across the country...
...over a new citizenship law that excludes Muslims.
In Pakistan, a special court has found former military President Pervez Musharraf...
...guilty of high treason and have sentenced him to death.
In the US, Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell dismisses Democrats' request...
...to call new witnesses during a Senate trial of President Donald Trump...
...that would take place after a House vote to impeach him.
In Algeria, thousands of students, teachers and other citizens rally in the capital...
...against the newly elected president and his offer of dialogue with the months-old protest movement.
Finally from South Sudan, President Salva Kiir and former rebel leader Riek Machar...
...have agreed to form a transitional unity government...
...even if they fail to resolve all their differences before a new deadline, the two leaders said.